he's one of our favorite guests and last
time we had him on it was before the
playing season and he'd just given his
quarterback his own golf cart and now
they're the one seed and he didn't play
a single down until week 18. how about
them apples i know if you put those
things together it sounds like he's not
a significant part of this team but he
definitely is over here i didn't mean to
say that he's david bochtiyari uh of the
offensive line of the one-seated green
bay packers back here on the show how
you doing david
i'm doing well thank you thank you for
having me back on i think uh
i think our relationship's really
starting to grow as uh i'm starting to
come on a more regular basis
once a season well david i hate to tell
you uh this is a tuesday uh your
quarterback has a regular tuesday spot
you know uh
it's up to you it's all i'm saying
you know what i mean have your people
talk to my people then okay people will
talk done people will talk how you doing
what's going on man how was it to get
back out there on the field in uh
detroit first time since last december
two decembers ago
it was great i mean i i miss being out
there i didn't you never really realize
how much you appreciate something until
it's taken from you so for me
i just love being out there just with
the guys the camaraderie competing
grinding going through
the adversity with them
on the field
it was very uh
it meant a lot to me and it took more
than enough time
for me to get back out there so i was i
was very excited so uh is it true that
you were planning to
just uh be there with the guys
not suit up and play with the guys and
get back out there on the field for a
divisional playoff game until
aaron rodgers texted you
is that a true story
yes
you know the idea was
for me i
i feel very confident
i played enough games i don't really
feel like i have like game jitters yes
so to speak and uh i know maybe some
coaches maybe like what we'd love to see
you know can you do it you know they
have that kind of idea of being worried
of like
you know we don't want you having you
know
any rust in a playoff game when it's do
or die
um
because for me personally as long as i
put back to back practices i knock off
the rest i go through the
mental gymnastics of certain plays and
adjustments aiming points in practice
i feel good i don't really need you know
i've played more than enough games
but then you know having
aaron i think aaron kind of wanted to
see it as well with the coaches so he
kind of shot me a text and i was like
all right man you know what
if you really really want me out there
i've had such a long history together
um i'm i'll do this for you
maybe you don't believe me when i tell
you i don't have rust uh
i gave him a little shot i'm like i know
you know
you know maybe you have a little more
rust than me or his weak one uh dilemma
but i mean i went out there it was
pretty smooth i felt good and then yeah
it was serious i was like you know what
i'm i did more than i even wanted to i
just kind of kept rolling and no one was
even talking to me i'm like all right
i'm not gonna try and you know bite off
more than i can chew on you know my
first game back
you know the the game the most important
game is the actual playoff one let's
this is this is a good test i think
everyone's happy um i proved anything i
not that i really need to prove anything
to them but i approve them that
i did fine in the game so let's just
call it a day 27 snaps i believe is the
actual count so was was aaron did you
just say hey man play or was he passive
aggressive what was he like what was the
text no he was really sweet about it he
texted me hey uh i really would love to
see you out there this week
and that was pretty much
the beginning of the conversation
and then i told him i said let's let me
go through my week progression i'm gonna
take one i'm gonna go wednesday thursday
off and go friday if i like how those
two days feel and we don't have any
um
any anomalies or variables come into
play then yes i'll strap it up with you
and i'll be out there with you and yeah
cause again i mean that's turf too
that's not uh that's not frozen tundra
you know what i mean like exactly that's
that's not that's not the most ideal not
the most uh right spongy surface for for
a knee joint yeah and so uh what was
your rehab like david what was it like i
mean
before we start turning to the the page
to playoffs but in the past what was
that like it felt like you felt like it
was never ending um
i just kept at it and had it and
um you know i've never been through
something like this before so for me it
was uh
you know i figured out what my new
normal was without having any reference
of what it was so before when i was
about to return the first time i'm like
this doesn't feel great at all
but
i mean i would assume you're not going
to feel awesome or the same
but apparently i guess what i was
feeling was not normal for the new
normal so
um again we then i had to go back in and
do a
a cleanup
they call it a scope and then then i
really started noticing okay this is how
i'm supposed to feel and then obviously
with that the other issue is now i have
two surgeries underneath my belt i
hadn't fully recovered from the first
one yet so
you know my knee is not the happiest
camper so now it's just trying to get
that to come back and i'm just blessed
and pleased that you know having good
communication with the gm and this team
that they just uh they kept me on the
roster and trusting me that i was gonna
be back and give me every opportunity to
come back in time david baktiari here on
the rich eisen show you know what else
isn't normal what's not normal is a team
wins
the conference regular season right to
get the one seed and then they get
healthier that's not normal
and it's both sides of the ball it's not
just you right it's jair alexander smith
coming back too what is the general
sense
around there about your chances to win
the super bowl right now david
what do you got for i mean that that's
the number one goal we saw we were last
year uh
we have a really good
we have a great team very balanced
we know where our eyes are set and
that's
uh i think you can kind of feel the
confidence in the building
especially with
all of us kind of coming back that kind
of resets a new standard on each of
those
uh position groups as well
uh at the end of the day nothing's given
everything's earned you got to go out
there saturday or sunday and you got to
prove it so if i think for us
we're excited for opportunity and we're
just kind of chomping at the bit to see
what our opponent is and
get uh get that weeks
i guess almost two weeks work
worth of work and
uh go show it yeah i know i mean because
it i usually ask hey you know
is there the same sense as the last time
you were there and usually that's years
apart
not like the next year you know like the
next year where you got it again if if
i'm not mistaken it was the first time
in aaron rodgers career there was a home
field advantage throughout you know with
an nfc championship game at home for him
right and so uh because the you hear
that he did have home field throughout
never got to the nfc championship game
as elon manning i think pointed out
during the manning cast a couple weeks
ago so is it the same feeling or the
same sense that last year we had this
feeling we didn't get it and that
actually gives you a a different footing
here
for
you you know the like i said the feeling
in the locker room is
uh confidence not arrogance
which i like
uh
and yeah last year we were
very confident we knew we had a really
good team
and i think this year we had the same
recipe we had a really good team
uh
every year is different
but uh
so i'm hoping this year will be
the same for the most part but a little
bit different obviously getting over
that hump because i mean i'm up for four
in this two championship games and i
would love to finally get over that hump
for my fifth one
wow uh so
how is rogers different he said he's out
of f's to give he told pat last week
so
yeah do you sense that is it different
oh yeah no definitely i think you know
he's he's really good at
compartmentalizing he's probably one of
the best people i know
compartmentalizing
a lot of things going on not only just
uh from a job perspective but life
perspective
so
uh i'm glad that he's kind of blown off
a little bit of steam and kind of
telling people how it is and not just
harboring these emotions and resentments
and really just being him kind of
speaking his mind not really scared of
you know any sort of backlash i mean
he's a very bright intelligent
individual it's okay to kind of show
that um not just from
a pc standpoint so
uh seeing him
kind of tell people how it is i think
it's great because he definitely does it
behind closed doors
he does it behind closed doors with who
with his teammates and and with folks
yeah i mean yeah when we have banter you
know getting them riled up getting them
on certain topics and getting them
rolling and it's fun so
i think anyone that is you know gets in
front of a camera has a big broadband
uh when they speak uh since being
broadcast out there you kind of like to
temper some of those uh certain
thoughts and sentiments i mean i'm happy
for him that you're able to just let it
out i know that and and i've i've said
here before some of the stuff that he is
saying on on outside of the sports world
you know i don't see eye to eye with him
on there but the whole business of of
him not deserving the mvp because of it
is ridiculous how did that land with you
david
i think it's hilarious um
i think it's kind of
i i mean for me
the fact that it's even something that
we're talking about uh
i think it's something that you can you
can't sit back and the only thing you
can do is sit back and laugh at it i
mean we're talking about it's the most
valuable player
player football we play football
so judge it for what it is
we're not you know it's not the most you
know valuable person not the most
valuable uh
you know
person in the world we're talking about
the sport
to judge the sport for what the sport is
because that's the integrity of
uh
uh of getting mvp so
if we're gonna
the voters or whoever votes for it i
didn't even know how they even go about
it or who even gets put in position but
if they're gonna start
uh
painting
how we're voting then i mean that's
that's their prerogative and there's
gonna be ripple effects for that there's
no doubt and that's the only reason why
i bring it up with you is because it's
an actual voter who said it you know
what i mean if it was just like somebody
from somewhere that doesn't have the
vote i wouldn't be bringing it up to you
but that's an important
i'm hoping i'm hoping they just more
wanted him for more like a publicity son
or something i i
that is like i i'm hoping that that was
really what they're more going after is
like
you know
because if that's really how they think
uh
man
where where are we trending
david bach tiara here on the rich eisen
show and i also had aj dillon on the
other day i love that guy i'd never met
him before you know wearing overalls no
shirt and and
you know he and he and i i i've met
aaron jones and interviewed him before
and i think he's delightful too but
dylan is kind of a guy that you know
you can you could you can get go rolling
in the fourth quarter when you got to
get this thing wrapped you know what i'm
saying like he gives you that option as
opposed to well aaron's got to find
avante with chips on you know
down and every game on the line and
obviously that's that's that's a good
that's a good combination to have with
the chips down in the game on the line
but dylan gives you a different
dimension
and i'm i'm wondering what you in the
line room thinks of that concept to wrap
a game up
yeah like i said before we're a very
balanced team and even offensively we've
gotten more bounce seeing him kind of
come into his own
uh and show any more of his
personalities compared to his year uh
something i actually really enjoy i've
always enjoyed guys who perform on the
football field and then start showing
their personality and not the
personality in the locker room not the
other way around um i think kind of clay
kind of instilled that in me when i was
younger so as long as you you ball you
do what you want to do on the field you
can be whoever you want locker room
uh so
what we we enjoyed i i think he's he's
the entertaining guy uh
and
i mean you said the best he's got those
big legs and he knows how to
he isn't someone that is going to go
down by one two even maybe three guys
and that's
uh
dynamically for our offense yeah adding
that other element is great especially
when we talk about closing out a game we
need to get those a little bit of
yardage we need to kind of lean forward
we need to kind of beat up
the uh the defense that's you know he
fits that makeup and that mold to a tee
for what you want well david i
appreciate you coming on here and using
your real voice instead of that uh that
that video you put out of you being back
you know back before and then retweeting
it that was frightening my children saw
it um but it's okay we got through it
that's not uh weird at all but that's
you know it's okay so you express
yourself i appreciate it
uh thank you i always enjoy being on
here oh no absolutely so uh my people
will talk to your people about uh
tuesdays with david um we can do that um
and my part of your your people i guess
is uh mike del tufo my sound guy who's
got how many shares of uh packer stock
do you have dose but i gave one away oh
so you only have one i really only have
one so i was yeah i'm limited she's
still technically
uh up the flow chart from you david with
that one share
is that cool yeah he definitely beaten
me so you don't have well didn't aj
dylan get some i think dylan got some
stock in the latest um
right did that happen i think like a few
packers players so you didn't get you
you you didn't get any packers stock
david didn't do that no no
too busy rehabbing too busy rehabbing
and just getting ready
exactly i got to keep the main focus the
main focus that's right you have no
money after you spend it on the golf
cart too right you're not exactly tapped
out
i think i should have got a paper with
that one right there is that where
where's the golf cart now that's got to
be in some shed now it's like zero
degrees out you're not winging around on
a golf cart right now we we roll it all
year
come on every day going down to practice
are you nice
oh yeah i mean he's got uh he's got a
all-terrain tires
on the front of it we're prepared what
anything that can happen so the
all-terrain tires were on it when
delivered during the summer in case of
this moment where you may have to use it
deep into january into february as well
that's what you're saying exactly the
only thing that i have a big issue when
it comes to the card is yes you know how
he takes care of it i'm like can it get
washed at least once i mean the salt is
going to erode it
um
when i give a nice gift like i would at
least expect for him to take you know
yeah take take decent care of it but
again it's his gift that's his it's not
mine okay
and he doesn't tarp it there's no
there's no there's really just the
elements just go and go well the the
nice thing is at least he puts it
underneath the you know uh
we're going to be parked in the loading
dock here at the stadium um because we
have all of our facilities everything's
all in-house in the stadium and then we
go drive out to practice so at least
it's covered okay um for the most part
you're a good teammate david you're
practicing about that you're good
teammate man you give him all terrain
tires in august just in case in the
event of just now you play when he you
know he texts you i'd like to see you
out there i mean you know there may be
eyes in bhaktiari but in david but
you're really a team player so
appreciate the time here as always yeah
that's very nice appreciate your friends
take care david i know you don't do this
a lot so uh you'd be well and let's chat
down the line next couple weeks all
right y'all take care back back at you
that's david bachtiari everybody he's
back
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here